vladimir putin there wrapping up that
impromptu press conference taking place
inside the kremlin i suspect in moscow
he said the kiev government is failing
to implement our agreements we have
recognized the borders of the uh two
regions lohansk and donetsk
we will be using armed forces abroad he
has confirmed what has happened away
from that scene that you were just
looking at inside the upper house the
russian parliament this includes
military assistance to perform
all our obligations he said live now to
moscow and our correspondent there dorsa
jabari so dorsa i guess this was really
a foregone conclusion that he would get
the green light that he was looking for
certainly but i think uh peter i have to
tell you it happened so quickly that
we're still trying to process everything
the the events that have unfolded over
the past few hours first
the request that he uh the agreement
that he signed last night first went to
the parliament the duma here earlier
today and that was ratified and signed
by mps and then there was this request
that we hadn't heard at all anything
about until we heard that the upper
house of parliament was convening a
special session to vote on what vladimir
putin had asked of them his request was
to approve troop deployments outside of
russia and the parliament met very
quickly and in i would say less than an
hour the senators all voted 153 of them
unanimously to approve vladimir putin's
request and he is of course the
commander-in-chief in this country at
that session in the upper house of the
country's parliament
we heard from various high-ranking
ministers who urged that this needs to
be approved because as um the defense
minister said that russia needs to
protect the local population in those
regions that have been declared
independent as of last night in donetsk
and lugansk
and then we just found out that
following a meeting with the president
of azerbaijan vladimir putin said he
will speak to the press about everything
that's been happening and we saw him we
were expecting him to walk out with his
um azerbaijani counterpart but he came
out alone he took very few questions and
he left very quickly it was less than 15
minutes i think but he was he made it
very clear that this is something that
needed to be done he
wanted the approval that he got and one
reporter asked them so where are these
troops going what is their line that
they're going to into in donbass and he
said i haven't
said they will go anywhere yet they're
not going anywhere yet
so he made it very clear that he has not
officially deployed any russian troops
to the newly declared republics but i
think the most important line that came
from the russian president is that he
said that they recognized all the
documents including
the constitution where the borders are
indicated i think this is a very
important point according to the
constitution of those two republics now
independent republics
their uh administrative regions are much
greater than the actual regions they
control because that is under the
control of the ukrainian government so
this has been the question since last
night everybody's asking
where are the borders going to be drawn
vladimir putin was asked as well he said
that is still
up for discussion and he even admitted
that some of those
lines cross into ukraine the
administrative lines that the newly
independent stakes claim they're in
control of he said that needs to be
discussed at a later date i think this
is very important to keep in mind the
boundaries and the the lines that will
define these new independent states
have to be agreed upon with the
government in kiev of course that is a
government that russia does not really
have much faith in or believe in even
the russian foreign minister as well as
the president said they don't really see
them as having any sovereignty so it's
going to be very difficult to see how
this can all be worked out when the only
peace agreement they had has been
virtually destroyed uh over the past 24
hours vladimir putin also said that the
mints agreement is no longer standing so
it remains to be seen what will happen
in the coming hours and days
but when it comes to the borders of
these two new
republics that come under the umbrella
the watchful eye if you will dorsa of
the powers that be in the kremlin i.e mr
putin
is it something of a diplomatic
conjuring trick a slight of hand when he
says look i've got the approval to
deploy troops abroad but i haven't
deployed troops abroad because the
reality is he doesn't have to deploy
troop support abroad officially because
he's got russian peacekeepers on the
ground in that region already and i
guess very quickly they could literally
just change their uniforms rip off one
insignia put on another insignia and hey
presto they go from being peacekeepers
to being russian soldiers on the ground
in eastern ukraine
certainly i think one of the things on
this um
request from president putin to the
parliament was that
he could deploy troops anywhere at any
time for any length of time
to carry out any task and i think that's
what could possibly take place in
donbass these so-called peacekeepers
that they haven't the russian government
hasn't even confirmed that they've sent
them in we've had underground reports of
them being present there um it could
possibly be a situation where they were
initially peacekeepers and they could
then become part of the russian military
it's a very very gray area at the moment
and i think it's designed to be that way
by the officials here and by the
president i think there's a deliberate
uh effort by putin to carry out these
chess moves as we've seen over the past
few days
sequencing of events that we've seen
unfold within narrative that we've heard
all lead to where we are right now which
is uh honestly a very dangerous
situation and all parties agree that
things are really very much beyond the
point of diplomatic talks diplomatic
efforts i think in the coming hours
we're going to hear from u.s president
joe biden and
we'll have to see how the government in
kiev also reacts i think their response
to all of this will be key as to how uh
vladimir putin decides to make his next
move dorsa for the moment thank you so
much dosa jabari they're our
correspondent in moscow live now to
vienna and